all right welcome to a very special
edition of beginner breakdown so special
we couldn't even invite Mike comer so
mike is uh he's not here right now he's
let's say he's attending the reception
for Fabiano Cara Juana and that's the
excuse we'll use for why he's not here
if you don't like that excuse he has to
go to Phoenix
soonish so he couldn't be here all right
so today we're going to look at the
Greek gift sacrifice so uh I suppose I
can I can set it up here on the board to
get a basic example going my name is
Jonathan Krantz
and today we'll be going over the the
Greek gift sacrifice so here it is in
its very very basic form always there's
going to be more pieces on the board and
it's going to determine if what will be
successful in attacking the King so this
is one of the the oldest known attacks
on a castled King that involves a bishop
that can sacrifice or offer itself up as
a gift for the H pawn and then a knight
if I know how to draw arrows they can
come in quickly to g5 with a check and
in comes the Queen so white will be
sacrificing material and hoping to
checkmate black for example white offers
the gift so you almost always have to
accept when you don't accept you're
probably worse because you're at least
down upon but also the H file is open so
you almost always have to accept though
we'll see one game today where somebody
did not accept and we'll see how well
that worked out okay so quickly the
knight comes in now in this position we
gave up a piece so we better be
checkmating black white black has two
retreats that he can do I'll make them
green so you feel safe and then he has
he has to advances in red because it's
so scary but often you do have to
advance
and sometimes you're just up a piece
because white gave up a piece after all
hmm
so normally there's four lines you have
to calculate almost always the King h8
line is the easiest to refute because
everyone in here sees the checkmate all
right they everybody sees it right so
yeah so almost always you can't go back
on the h-file does the Queen is coming
to the h-file
with check so that line almost never
works mmm now sometimes this line
doesn't work for similar reason white
will play here anyway even if it's it's
not check which means black has the
extra option of trying to get his rook
out of the way so very often I mean it
totally depends on the position here
there's not a lot of pieces on the board
so it's but ok but you have to move your
rook somewhere and then white has a
choice of two different checks and so
often it's you check here and then
sometimes you you check mate which will
we'll see some examples of this in the
game okay this check is the King to h6
is often bad when there's a bishop on
this diagonal here there's a one because
when there is there's usually discovered
checks and sometimes there's a queen
here that we can take all right but not
whoa not a white queen but okay but
sometimes when there's a bishop on this
diagonal you can imagine moving this
night away will be checked so we can
take something okay and often when we
play the King g6 line the Queen now that
she's unable to go to the h-file she'll
go to g4 the next most active Square and
from here she'll be threatening
discovered checks so we'll see this in
action in one of our first featured game
of the day so this game and let's see
we'll look at it from from blacks point
of view was from the amateur and premier
tournament that just took place a couple
weekends ago when we were celebrating
our seventh anniversary as the Chess
Club so I thought it was only
appropriate we do a topic about gifts
because it's our anniversary so Scott
Anderson had the white pieces
and he's a 1500 player and in the first
round he got paired with Marik Zhang an
800 player so it seemed like it would be
a slam dunk for Scott but unfortunately
for him he didn't know about the Greek
gift sacrifice so he got he had a you
know real shock when you know suddenly
his his King was was in trouble alright
and let's check out the game alright so
it was a Queens gambit accepted I don't
know if either player really knows these
lines very well but uh okay so black
accepted the gambit White has more
central pawns so obviously most
aggressive is efore that's the most
ambitious plan just take the center and
if we get the pawn back then we just
have a great center for no reason
Scott chose a less ambitious plan but
it's perfectly fine he's just going to
get hit get the pawn back and then he's
going to just say I have more central
pawns and I'll be slightly better for a
long time any questions no okay alright
so they develop their pieces kind of
normally alright and this this move
makes some sense okay and now the first
strange move of the game was played
normally in this structure black wants
to play the moves like c5 and Knight to
c6 and attack the center we gave white
the center like when we took on c4 and
move to so we better attack it also
usually we're going to play some
combination of these moves and we're
going to put the Bishop over on b7 well
notice the bishop we trapped them in
when we play D six so we got to be
thinking of where we're going to put
them so often he belongs on the long
diagonal but definitely we need to be
putting a lot of pressure in the center
here so c5 and ninety six and even a6
are kind of automatic moves that should
be played by black but instead alright
knight c6 which is pretty strange
because now you're not going to play c5
in the near future so you're not going
to be undermining the center this move
might be okay if you ever get to play e5
but if whites careful that should never
happen but
okay let's see all right why developed
and black one here and a funny story
about this too so one day somebody
showed up for a tournament not too long
ago and we had this similar sort of
thing happened in two blitz games we
played right before the tournament
started
he put his his pieces right next to each
other and so I moved my pond he did
something like he castled and then I
forked him and then we played again and
we switched colors and it was like
almost the same position and I played
here with the same threat he did
something and then I forked him and then
he got so angry that he said I'm not
playing in this tournament and he left
so alright so
efore makes a lot of sense here you're
threatening to fork and you're building
a center your Bishop has a has a chance
to get out but all right everybody
castles which is fine
but here what does make a truly big
strategical mistake in this position the
move Bishop d2 was played I guess what
was thinking this is the next most
logical piece I want to develop but I
asked him after the game why didn't you
put your bishop over here on g5 and do
you know what he said he said there's a
there's a pawn in the way which is true
but this is how chess is we have a
problem we want to put our Bishop so I'm
more active but there's a pawn in the
way so the solution here should have
been really easy you just push the pawn
and then you're threatening a fork so
black better stop you and then you get
your Bishop to a good square instead
when you just play the move Bishop d2
you're blocking your Queen the bishop
isn't really doing anything here so it's
it's it was a very unfortunate move and
Scott's Scott's a dear friend he plays
it I'd like all of our tournaments and
he just recently reached 1500 he was
1300 for the longest time but lately he
started to do really well in a couple
tournaments and he got all the way up to
1500 so it was unfortunate now black
could do the same thing that's the piece
you want to move but black had the right
idea I want to play e5 well I want to
play e5
now my Bishop King can get out all the
way to g4 but only if I know how to draw
arrows all right wait does it have to
take here he did you probably don't have
to but taking it should be fine
black took here now I definitely
wouldn't trade here as in the game I
would probably just put my bishop back
so now if you trade with me you bring my
bishop to this nice diagonal making it a
little bit harder for you to get your
bishop out because I'm tickling your
beep on but mostly there's going to be
no Greek gift sacrifice because anytime
you play Knight to g4 now I have two
people protecting the g4 square so
that's never going to work okay
but in the game he took and black took
back and now blacks Bishop has a lot of
scope we're tacking on the Kings side
the Queen side and Scott made a very
mysterious move here that I didn't get
he just moved his knight back perhaps
he's going over to the Kings side for
defense but but okay we have our trio of
pieces that are all set up for a great
gift but perhaps Scott's trying to trick
him into taking the beep on which is
also good and so you got a couple
choices here but all right best is going
in for the Greek gift hmm okay and
surprisingly Scott did not accept the
gift which is a big mistake I'll show
you the game and then we'll look at what
happens if he does decide to accept it
so here marek played a move the kind of
move that I teach to a lot of people and
none of you know my rule that I teach my
students but he's already making it look
bad because it's it's not exactly the
best here normally when you take
something inside of your opponent's
territory you can get trapped so you
want to just retreat so that you're not
going to get stuck behind the territory
too often I see people they take stuff
and then they stay in there and suddenly
they lose their pieces because you're
too close here though black can get away
with
just continuing to put pieces here and
if here a lot of moves win you know
rerouting a queen to the h-file
wins even this move wins if you take
with the night you know the king gets to
go for a little walk and yeah that's not
where your king belongs and and yet if
you take with a pawn we can go here all
right sort of threatening to like go
here and start the King walk again and
whenever you do this the this line will
will win for for black who's checking in
and picking up the bishop so that
actually does work better but that was
that was I guess hard to calculate going
back as fine to black is still like
still doing doing fine here all right
f3 Scott really didn't want the night
going to g4 because with the night on g4
the queen is coming in and he's in
trouble
so here black has sort of a problem he
wants to put the Queen on h4 but there's
a knight in the way and surprisingly
there's six legal moves that the knight
can make and they all win every single
it doesn't matter if you go backwards
block your Bishop they all win so he
played the coolest one Scott said you
can't put a knight on g4 and Merrick
said yes I can so the threat is Queen to
h4 so Scott should stop that he should
put a queen or a bishop on a one to
prevent that check but instead he took
so does anybody see the mate in three or
at least the first move
it's mating three in this position so
what should black play here
Queen h4 all right one move and now this
is an important decision you have two
checks on each two you can go in with a
queen or the bishop first and one of
them wins and one of them loses so you
got to be really careful here so I'll
give you guys a second to figure it out
now yeah you want to say it
the bishop right the queen is doing a
great job preventing the the White King
from running away so we go in with the
bishop all right why does one move so
that was easy
right so we have any discovery we want
which where should we put the bishop yes
g3 exactly now the king will never be
able to run away so after he moves here
I hope everybody sees the checkmate and
the game ended
he's got actually resigned here but okay
this is how the game would have finished
so that was unfortunate also unfortunate
for Scot was he placed in the Wednesday
tournament so the Wednesday after this
game
his opponent went in for a Greek gift
and Scott immediately resigned without
calculating which is a shame because he
was winning he could have just run his
King around and he would have won the
game but instead he just said Bishop
takes h7 like I resign and he like just
left and it's like you really got to
calculate so let's go through this game
at least and see what would have
happened had Scott accepted the gift
because we can't just be scared our
opponent took our pawn I must be getting
checkmated like oh no you know but you
have to you have to accept the gift and
then you need to calculate because after
the knight comes in we have four king
moves and so they all should be
calculated because if you survive in any
one of those variations then you're up a
bishop so let's see of course the king
h1 line is the easiest to refute because
we just check and checkmate all right
so that's the that's the easiest one
also easy to refute is this one because
there's a bishop on the same diagonal as
the King so we have any discovery we
want for example check and take a queen
all right so that's easy enough now the
two tough ones are going back and going
up so if you go back to g1 black plays
this move anyway all right it wasn't
Czech so white gets one move to find a
way to prevent them you can't move your
pawns don't work I see a lot of people
try to do this as if their King has a
escape but he doesn't have an escape
okay so white can move the rook and now
black has two checks and one is better
than the other which which one do you
like all right and then the King will go
here and unfortunately if you check
white can defend he has a knight you so
unfortunately white survives in this
line so here you have to actually take
on f2 all right and so the King moves
over and now there's no direct mate
we're not we're not just checkmating
white in any way and so we can win the
long way one good plan is to put this
bishop here and here and threaten check
mate with the Queen on g2 unfortunate
arrows also bringing a rook over here to
the H file is very good taking a rook
and sacrificing for the bishop so you
can play Knight takes e4 takes g2 check
is a is very hard to meet so it's now
that not there's not one good right move
here there's several moves to win so you
can't you can't play that line okay so
we got one option to really consider and
that's this one and Scott should have
tried to play this way because now if
you play the normal move in a great gift
you might actually be a little surprised
because all right white will try
to kick you off the G file so you don't
have any any discoveries all right
likens say no I'm saying white tries
again and okay so the Queen gets to stay
on the file but unfortunately now the
bishop unleashes an attack on the Queen
and so the Queen will have to leave the
G file and white will actually survive
this this attack you'll only be slightly
better though he's down a piece but you
know the king is still quite exposed
okay let's see so actually the best move
here is a move it you know his opponent
might not have considered which is
moving the knight back attacking the
bishop and the computer wants you know
you to like give up your bishop and
somehow defend your king but if you play
a human move like saving your bishop
you'll see this line is very very
similar to the King G one line from
earlier because it's the same exact
position except the bishop has shifted
from c4 to b3 okay and so the same sort
of stuff or same sort of stuff will
happen if all right if it wants to work
but okay Scott obviously should have
tried to play this way he should have
tried to play the King g3 line yeah it's
so confusing but be sure to play that
because then he at least had chances of
surviving you can't just say oh he
sacrificed a bishop and then he's going
to get a knight check and just be scared
you have to actually calculate there are
four lines you have to calculate Oh No
but you know if you survive in any one
of them then you're up a bishop so yeah
you're constantly should be on alert all
right now it's funny so the next game I
wanted to show you is the same opening
except it's uh it's white that will win
and I'm not even sure who played this
game I just remember this game and I
tried to look it up for this lecture I
really thought this was a sign it's game
versus somebody and when I tried to look
it up I couldn't find it anywhere so
hopefully you at home
in the comments telling you a game this
is because otherwise I just made it up
but but this might be sine it's the
first undisputed world champion of chess
so the very same opening was played i
think III was played before the night
move but uh but okay so it was the same
exact opening that we just saw only this
time instead of this bad move we replace
it with another bad move again black
really wants to play like c5 a 696 b5
Bishop e7 that sort of stuff on the
Queen side this check alright it doesn't
it doesn't too much do too much because
Knight want it white wanted to put a
knight on c3 anyway so it's not obvious
what the the bishops doing here and his
follow up certainly wasn't wasn't very
logical all right and then you played
here which is again again very strange
and these lines you should be playing
for c5 and occasionally giving away two
isolated Queens pawn that's that's the
sort of situation that usually occurs in
these lines now you're not playing c5
the knight doesn't have c6
I don't know what this bishops doing so
all in all not not very good play by
black and he continued in very strange
style by taking this Knight which is bad
for at least four reasons one you're
trading a bishop for a knight to you
move the same piece two times to take a
piece that moved once thirdly you're
building white Center so that's good for
white and fourthly you're letting this
Bishop come to a square that is now very
very strong for them so it's not the
best play by black so black should
Castle here while he has a chance all
right but instead he developed a knight
and now white stopped black from
castling and this is something that's a
pretty important idea well I see my
students normally they say my opponent's
going to do this and then they stop it
but for some reason when it's castling
they don't know that they can stop it
castling is just another move and that's
when you notice your opponent's plan
you can stop it with the move Bishop a3
you can't castle through check so you
know black has a problem he can't castle
alright so black comes up with a plan to
castle it's not a good one he's going to
take his very best piece and he's going
to maneuver it to e7 to block the bishop
and then he'll be able to castle so
because he's played poorly in the
opening he has to you know continue with
a strange plan of taking his best piece
in making two moves to put in on a bad
square so all right but first he started
by attacking the bishop all right so the
bishop went backwards you'll notice that
with the pawns here the bishop is
unlikely to ever sacrifice or to ever do
anything successful on this diagonal so
he went back to d3 and black began his
plan of maneuvering a knight to e7 all
right for now we're attacking upon her a
so I assume you don't have to worry
about your pawn but there's no reason to
give it away for free either so all
right he attacked and and black achieved
his plan so all right in this position
wide advanced black did Castle white
played a five threatening some some
checks on h7 which are easily to parry
if you just play h6 then you don't get
great gifted but okay he went here so
now the big question is does Bishop
takes h7 work so we'll investigate it
was played and black accepted of course
and the night came to g5 alright so
again four moves to consider as always
the King h8 line is very quick right
easy enough alright so we look at the
the other lines here is actually a very
fast mate for white as well again we
bring our queen to the normal square
would when they go back you bring your
Queen to h5
so we're threatening checkmate all right
you have to move your rook and now
there's there's two moves you can take
here or you can you can check here both
lead to mate but one is faster taking
the F pawn is actually slower here due
to the following line the fastest mate
is Czech and Queen h8 mate
notice that the knight is in a pin so
then I can't come back and do the normal
defense that you would expect of them if
the knight was not in a pin then of
course we would take on f7 first but
okay so there's no going back there's
only going forward and somehow black
who's played you know very poorly every
single move found the best move in this
position and somehow for the rest of the
game he plays okay but he played here
which is objectively the best but it's
still losing this is kind of the
trickier move so we should look at this
first and I'll ask the audience what do
you think white should play here in this
position
there so we don't we don't have Queen h5
f4 f4 is part of the right idea and it's
it's a pretty good move the moves f4 and
Bishop c1 are very good but uh but
actually the the strongest is just to
play queen g4 they when they take away
h5 from our queen we go to the next
strongest square which is g4 question
Queen d2 threatening discoveries all
right I'll not get discovered all right
yeah it's a thing all right but it's
better to go here because you are
threatening a pretty serious check just
the simple Queen h4 is very strong so
it's so strong in fact that a black
should stop the Queen from going there
with Knight f5 now what white would like
to do he can't do it but he would like
to check and say checkmate
but it's not checkmate so if the knight
were protected we would be threatening
checkmate in all right we got these two
pawn moves and the bishop move to
protect the pond so our Queen can go
back with the check and they and these
two win f4 and Bishop c1 they both win
this is a very winning move but a best
is actually f4 so we're threatening
check and mate also sometimes the rook
will come and the only way black can
stop the threat of Queen h3 is by giving
up the f7 square which is a Royal fork
so all right so that in that line you
just lose your queen alright so yeah so
that's that's enough to know that if you
have to play this move you can't put
your King on h6
okay so this was tried in the game so
again I'll ask the audience what move do
you think white should play here yes
Queen g4 excellent right so we put our
queen on the most active square so black
says to white you need to get your Queen
off the G file he played the move f5
alright please I beseech you get off the
G file and white says now so black tries
again yes you are allowed to take here
if you wish he probably didn't do it
because it's important to control the f6
square we don't want the King to run
away the biggest thing in these
positions is containing the King because
if he runs away then you know we might
not have a discovery and we might not
actually checkmate them the pawn is is
quite good on e5 and going here
threatening a discovery is a it's very
tough to meet alright so you try it
again put the Queen just stays on the G
file so now black realizes that this
check is going to pick up the Queen if
he doesn't do anything so he moves the
Queen allowing the discovery but this
time it's it's you're not winning the
Queen at the end all right so the King
King went back and now white is begging
for you to just take this rook where
things are still bad for black but
you're not getting immediately
checkmated and that's that's the key
and then the white move here is kind of
hard for a lot of people to find
we've been looking just at the one
quadrant over here on the Kings side but
there's a whole big board going on so we
don't want to lose focus so I'll ask you
because a lot of people have had trouble
finding this move here what should white
play in this position
alright capture here
right yeah black we'll just take the
night it's still very scary but but okay
boy white has a much simpler move yeah
all right Knight takes g7 hmm all right
I can pin you what else can I do
I can do a discovered attack on your
queen but okay maybe I just pin you you
have this chick you also have this chick
like when your knight
it's tricky that's tricky
yeah boy it actually has a quite a
simple move here that just wins
convincingly yeah so yeah so it's it's
one of these pieces but it's not
actually on the kingside one of these
pieces goes to the Queen side which
square g5 alright so if I go back am i
escaping yeah yeah I assume so I go back
and if you try to make me sometimes I
have like a queen that I can protect I
might lose my knight so I gotta I gotta
be be careful here how I defend yeah
yeah I got a yeah I got a not get mated
but uh you know I don't want to I don't
want to I don't want to move lose my
knight either this would be terrible
whoops what's that hmm yeah what is this
simple okay
in this position white plate here with
at least two threats that you see most
people probably see this threat and this
threat but the even bigger threat is
checkmate
so black couldn't decide should I lose
my queen or should I get checkmated so
he resigned it's a tough choice it's a
tough choice if you resign you get to go
home and you don't have to play this
position anymore
so that's that's what he played you
think you'd lose your queen yeah he
could do that but you got to suffer for
a long time when you resign you get to
go to Froyo you know you get to chill
out
all right it was a tough choice okay
9:06 let's check it out let's check it
out
only if it only if it lets me that's the
only if it lets me alright let's let's
see let's
all right somehow I figured it out which
night moved Yannick Knight f6 all right
I at least have this check also I can
probably just win this pawn and you're
in a pin so I'm at I'm attacking all of
your pieces anybody yeah yeah it's yeah
yeah yeah you can at least try something
and can only lose a lot of material but
uh he was playing Stein it's so I guess
he knew it was up so he resigned all
right and now there's one game that uh
that I want to show you did app it I
guess it'll be the last game that I show
you guys mostly I want to show it just
because that the tactical finish at the
end is so cool in this game is uh not
well known so let's get to it all right
the Rui Lopez all right right so the so
the most common you know a six-night f6
Stein it's like to play d6 but in this
game it was the Sleeman variation the
most aggressive so black has opened up
this diagonal for which sometimes you'll
be danger for his king but he's hoping
to get all this pieces out really fast
and he's hoping you know to go start a
King side attack on white so he's
offering white upon so that he can get a
lead in development and take the center
white did not accept at first okay but
now he accepts when black doesn't have a
chance to play e4 all right then let's
see what happened here okay
black developed black Castle White
Castle black castle and white decided he
was going to win upon here which you
know you don't have to do if you want to
you want to be safer but okay he took
black took back and white took this
pawned
and we'll count after this this Bishop
takes here to see who has how many ponds
she'll notice it's four on four on the
Queen side and three on two on the King
side so white is up upon black has quite
a lot of compensation here though all of
these pieces are developed and they make
a lot of sense and leave a strong
impression going towards the the White
King so it's it is is pretty tough all
right white noticed that and he wanted
to start trading some pieces eliminating
some of the key attackers I he played
here he's trying to get that dark
squared Bishop and he wants to trade as
many pieces as possible to eliminate the
possibility of an attack so blacks plan
was to get all of his pieces out as
quickly as possible so instead of moving
the bishop immediately he just defended
it with the Queen all right white
attacked the bishop and protected the
knight on e5 and black did not move the
bishop what move did black play that's
not moving the bishop yeah which one he
played rook a to d8 this rook is is
pretty good on the F file so white
played a very sneaky move c3 the idea is
to play Queen b3 and if your King moves
you take the bishop and if you you block
something like Bishop e6 then the Queen
is coming down here and starting to
gobble up all the pawns over there it's
still quite dangerous but a black
decided all right I'm not going to let
you you get away with that and now
you'll see he's weights about to make a
big mistake he plays here hoping to eat
the bishop but okay we have our trio so
this game is a lot more complex due
mostly to the bishop he rips bishop here
on e3 which which will not be taken by
the Queen in the game instead we have
our Greek gift so hopefully everybody
knows the first move Bishop takes h2
all right so white takes the bishop and
now the knight comes in after the bishop
sacrifices the knight comes in to g4
with check so once more we have four
moves and fortunately in this case two
of them are very quick to review okay
King h1 is the same as always in
checkmate all right
and walking into a discovery is bad news
yeah a lot of people like to take upon
and then a queen but you know I prefer
to take a bishop and then a queen so you
can take the bishop and then take the
Queen so that's yeah that's one way to
play okay so there's there's two moves
to look at going to g1 and going to g3
King g1 was played in the game
so first we'll have a look at a King g3
and it's it's quite tricky now normally
we put our Queen on g4 but there's a
bishop on e3 that will take our queen so
that the normal move doesn't work here
so actually what black wants to do is
put a queen on d6 but of course there's
a problem there's a knight exactly so
how should black kick the night away so
that he can play Queen d6 yes b5 exactly
and the computer thinks this check on d6
is so important that it wants to just
defend the night and let you take it
because now you're controlling d6
that check is pretty bad but if you
defend like a human and you just move
your knight black it's the plays check
exactly okay y can defend and the queen
gets to go to the G file after all so it
took them longer maneuver but you made
it
and this discoveries are very annoying
you can try to get out of them but you
know every move wins you
you can put a bishop back here and do
some rook stuff you know it's it's
actually game over for for white you
know your king is not going to live
forever on h4 all right
so because of that he went backwards and
now black played a move that actually
loses but it looks so natural he played
here the losing move the problem is
white has this defensive resource which
was played so in this position now that
we understand that white is going to
play Bishop f4 to defend the h2 square
what can black play in this position
before he plays Queen h4 we need to
prepare it you know h6 to play g5
kicking a bishop what Bishop is it
kicking right so then one right so one
problem is okay so you're saying if he
plays it immediately then you're playing
G g5 and then you know his Bishop go
somewhere and now you fortunately your
queen can't even come over here because
you blocked you block the file further
yeah you block that diagonal for your
queen so so that's not it unfortunately
all right all right so the person
walking in the door right now right now
knows what black should play here
knowing that it's not Queen h4 all right
does anyone has anybody figured it out
it's tricky all right when the bishop
can go to f4 you want to make sure that
you can take it with a rook so we need
to get the bishop out of the way and we
can move the bishop and make a threat on
the knight and then okay of course if
you move the knight okay our Queens
coming in and it's going to be game over
so all right so ins but instead in the
game this move was played and white
correctly found the right resource
all right so black really wants to take
the bishop so he moves the bishop out of
the way he's starting to take the bishop
in white played a seemingly very natural
move in the game but this move actually
loses white has to find Queen d2 the
only move that wins you really want to
keep a piece here it's very important
because then you're guarding the crucial
h2 square okay in the in the game though
Bishop g3 was played and now Oh Joe
already knows it Joe already knows it a
spectacular move was played in this
position so we'll see who's that the
tactical genius in here and this is the
real reason I love this game because
this this next move is a it's truly a
beautiful move yeah no I know Joe sees
it yeah yeah
all right it is is a truly brilliant
move here
all right we are all right black does
not move the Queen it's a queen
sacrifice so what move is not moving the
Queen yeah you know Bishop f3 very
interesting what if I take you okay and
then I take your Bishop and now I have
more pieces than you and your tax Khan
that was unfortunate why didn't I take
your rook I can take your rook - so it's
this position and we're going to call on
Joe Gagne for the brilliant answer rook
takes F - right a brilliant move so he's
sacrificing the Queen which was accepted
in the game alright and now black
actually has mate in three moves all
right does anybody not named Joe Gagne
CE matin three yeah so you're suggesting
I'll try to move very carefully so it
doesn't mess up rook takes f1 then I am
a check so I'll take the rook
all right sure
all right I'll probably move my queen
and you didn't make me in three moves
alright alright so let's try again and
let's see the machine wanted me to play
this move so let's go ahead and play it
all right
White has one move and he's walking into
a discovery and now it's mating - and
now you see it you look excited
what is it rook d2 it's true that is
true I assume I'll play here right and
I'm not you're winning lots of material
but I'm not a I'm not mated so that's
that's the good news for me
I can even also you know take your rook
well I'm in check all right so I'll take
the bishop okay I ain't get mated that's
my big my big goal is to not get made it
in two moves all right Meredith sees
mating - I guarantee it
just walking in doesn't matter all right
does anybody see it yes excellent rook
h2 again one move for white I think I
can find it and now it's mating one and
surprisingly a lot of people can't find
this Maintenon yes rook h1 checkmate
yeah notice how that the knight and the
bishop are preventing the King from
running away okay so that's a that's the
great gift for you it's it's over it's
all over
it was checkmate alright so alright
that's okay sure
alright so thanks you guys for for
coming hopefully you learn something
about the Greek gift and you won't you
won't panic whenever it's it's played on
the board and just resigned because you
want to investigate there's four moves
you got to look at but uh but okay it's
it's one of the coolest and oldest
sacrifices of all time